foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
birthday
s
our show will begin shortly
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
let's shut him up
I am a shield of Rosaria and I will do
my duty
come on
[Music]
oh
please welcome to the stage Square Enix
president and CEO Takashi kirihu
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this celebration for Final
Fantasy 16.
with a joining us in person or watching
online
we thank you for being a part of our
show
but when I say our show
I mean all this is your show too
are fun sorry [__] [__] come on come on
a fan who is constant Support over the
years
of over the years has driven our
developers to achieve miracles
as for me well I'm just another fan like
you
a fan who is honored to serve as a new
CEO of Square Enix
thank you
and the fun who is so excited to meet
you all on this special day when we
present to you our latest instrument in
the flagship Final Fantasy franchise
[Music]
now
I don't know how you felt when you are
watching that radar we just saw
but I felt like a kid again
like a young boy in winter in 2001 1987.
[Music]
Who Loved RPGs who robbed Dragon Quest
which came
which came out the year before
and was amazing
I had to get my hands on the big new
thing
so
as a reward for my as a reward for
helping my parents pick oranges and
after begging them for an early
Christmas gift
and my father bought me the very first
Final Fantasy
and right off the bat
I was surprised no title screen
just some story tickets
I started to wonder if maybe my father
had vote the wrong game
but I kept praying and kept praying
and eventually
I left the castle and crossed the bridge
and then
screen changed
that music that moment
when tiger appears
that surprise that the right
still seared into my memory
from then on I was [__]
as Final Fantasy fan for life
yeah
whatever new title came out
I had I had I had to make time to pray
Forget homework forget eating forget
sleeping
I sleep in Christ anyway
one of my friends got into sports or
you know other activities but I was
focused on games
and yeah
I had more than a few teachers tell me
if you play games all the time
you are not going to succeed in life
but
that
exactly
very surprised to see me
I standing on this stage right now with
you
I believe games have games offer
infinite possibilities
they have the potential to alter the
cause of our rights
as a new CEO of Square Enix
I will continue to cherish those
childhood memories that instilled in me
a gamer's speed
and strive to deliver all of you all
about fans across the world
that entertainment that promises new
Unforgettable experiences
experience is that a powerful affirming
reverting delivered to you with the
cooperation of a business partner
on that note I'd like to share with you
a message
one of from one of the most valued
Partners Jim Ryan
I saw his relationship with Square Enix
goes back right to the start of
PlayStation's existence and that
partnership has never been stronger
we value everything that we do together
and appreciate your commitment to our
brand and our business
thank you again
thank you Jim
as I said before
scare Enix has produced works that have
changed people's lives including my own
and it is my promise
we will continue to do so
I won't craft moments and memories that
stay with you for Lifetime
I won't Square Enix to grow stronger and
better at providing experiences
that resonate with you now and forever
thank you
today we present to you our latest
efforts to do just that
Final Fantasy 16.
and as someone who has the chance to
praise the demo a bit earlier
or I can say is
nothing
because nothing I could say would do it
justice
even now even now thinking back to the
trader we just saw
I can't help but wonder what comes next
I'm sure it's the same for all of you
but it's honestly painful for me having
to wait until June 22nd to find out
we are all dying to Ram more about Final
Fantasy 16 right
okay let's get this show started
allow me to introduce one of our
greatest Creative Minds
Final Fantasy 16 producer knock yoshira
and localization director Michael
Christopher coach Fox
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
for such a great introduction
um that's I think it's like the first
time he's done this kind of English
speech in front of everybody it was a
great job right
[Applause]
um
yeah but again thank you very much for
telling us about your childhood your
passion as a gamer and where you want to
take Square Enix in the future
and
[Music]
and my name is Michael Christopher Koji
Fox translation and localization
director on Final Fantasy 16.
[Applause]
all right so Final Fantasy 16 is finally
releasing on June 22nd and as part of
today's pre-launch celebration we will
be delivering the latest information and
streaming on stage content from here in
Los Angeles
and so Final Fantasy 16 is the latest
installment in the series which we
Square enix's creative business unit 3
CBU 3 have worked on and developed for
so many years alongside Final Fantasy
14. all right
and so the development team and the
promotion team and our staff from all
around the world have been pouring their
hearts into delivering the best
narrative and gaming experience with
Final Fantasy 16 and today we would love
to share this pre-launch excitement with
all of you from this stage is
and so to the fans and the influencers
that have gathered here uh with us today
as well as everyone else around the
world watching on the stream please
enjoy the show
[Applause]
events
all right so today now is our opening
act allow me to introduce some of the
dev team members that we have brought
with us from Japan for the show today
all right come on everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so let's let the team
introduce themselves
please enjoy the show
[Applause]
all right and I am at the Final Fantasy
16's creative director and Main
scriptwriter uh kazatoyo my hero and I'm
looking forward to giving you a lot of
information about the game today
[Applause]
um
and hello everyone no sorry
okay okay
get up there so hello everyone my name
is uh ryota Suzuki and I am the combat
director on Final Fantasy 16. it's great
to meet you all
right
hello everyone I worked on Final Fantasy
16.
oh hey everybody I worked on the music
in Final Fantasy 16 on Master Yoshi's
okay
[Applause]
all right so let's ask these crazy guys
what's in store for you today uh on
today's panels
hi um
will be joined by Maximilian dude and
have a battle panel to show off the
game's action content I know
[Music]
and I'm a fan of Maximilian dude yes I'm
a big fan I'm kind of nervous
[Applause]
all right so again in this
packet we have
focusing some of the battle scenes um in
Final Fantasy 16 and actually be showing
you some real-time game play
what's up
[Music]
um
all right because this is the first
Final Fantasy game in the series that
goes full real-time action I wanted to
show you just how stylish the combat
could be
[Applause]
all right and then next up uh we will
have a panel on the game story and lore
uh done by mayrosan and myself as well
as uh the streamer Alana Pierce
[Applause]
and of course there won't be any
spoilers really really no nothing
nothing really no no no no no no no no
spoilers
all right so again we worked really
really hard
um to make the story and the narrative
very very engaging and we want to talk
all about it today so um with the help
of me we're gonna do our best yeah yeah
you got it good okay
[Applause]
all right and finally for our third
session we will have a soken sun as well
as Alex mukala having a session about
the game soundtrack and how music plays
a role in the game
[Applause]
it's okay
um
okay so um for today's panel um we're
going to be you know talking a lot about
sound but we're also maybe have some
video content we may be showing you
today for the first time ever and and
also during the panel if you happen to
see some instruments behind us that may
mean maybe we're gonna do something
[Applause]
I mean you say maybe but if you don't do
it now everybody's you know things are
gonna do it you have to do it right
[Applause]
Maybe
um
all right we have a lot of story for you
today but first we let these guys go
back and get ready for their panels
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
so yeah um you know we did this earlier
yesterday we did the rehearsal you know
we're a little bit nervous but now we
get up here on stage in front of you
guys it's a lot easier than we thought
all right so for the rest of the session
we're going to talk a little bit more
about some new information that we have
for you special today
but before again we have received a
special message from a special someone
as part of this opening ceremony so
let's start with that
this
[Music]
is
um
[Applause]
and so um that was a very special
message from the Final Fantasy brand
manager yoshinori and now I have all
this film lots of pressure and very
nervous to succeed
is
so um we all know uh is also the
producer of Final Fantasy 7 Final
Fantasy rebirth um which just dropped a
lot of information a couple days ago
all right and so this year
um the plan is to keep everyone excited
with not one but two final fantasies
Final Fantasy 7 rebirth and of course
Final Fantasy 16.
hello
which reminds me you look at Final
Fantasy VII and Final Fantasy 16 are
very very different types of games
foreign
um again they certainly are
um
the father of the final fantasy series
have always had this Mutual sentiment
that the Final Fantasy game is basically
what the creators at the time think is
best for the series
um so you're going to get lots of
different types of games and it's the
differences between the games that
really Define the series
but while the titles may be very very
different they're both going to have
that significant Final Fantasy feel and
we hope that you enjoy both of them
[Applause]
all right and so we had that video
message from but actually we have
two more videos messages
um from another special uh pair this is
gonna be a little bit of a surprise so
let's take a look
numbers
again
photography
says
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
they're not cpu3 yes
foreign
[Music]
was so massive and it was the first time
um that we were trying to create this
full real-time action game
um we knew that we couldn't do it by
ourselves
um and so we reached out um to these
companies such as Platinum Games who's
known for their action games as well as
the kingdom heart scene which is known
for their action content as well and ask
them to help us come together and create
something truly impressive
he must stop
so asking these teams to kind of
partially produce uh something for a
large scale title like this is usually
something they don't do they usually
create their own games
um and so um as they mentioned in their
videos you know they were you know kind
of reluctant to help us out but once
they heard about what we wanted to do
and they got on board
um they decided to go all out and they
went all out they realized we were
serious and so they went crazy as well
um it was really difficult
um both of their offices are in Osaka
we're in Tokyo
but we didn't let the the distance
hamper us and we got together and we
created something truly great
and again we couldn't have achieved the
scale that we did on Final Fantasy 16
without their helps so we really really
want to thank them for their assistance
yeah it must have been you know really
incredible to work with those teams
foreign
I mean we worked on them from the very
early parts of development and and asked
them to create all these things and they
created them right up to the beta
versions and once they had created these
beta versions they passed them over to
us but when we got them and we looked at
just the amount of content the crazy
things that they had done it was a lot
of work to get that in the game and get
it working because they had done such a
great job and so again we thank them so
much
[Applause]
now because it's still you know before
lunch we can't tell you exactly what
parts they did work on but once the game
is released we'll give all that
information so don't worry height s
[Music]
all right so now let's move on to
today's most important announcement
um
[Applause]
all right so thank you so much for your
patience the Final Fantasy 16 demo is
finally here and releasing tomorrow
[Applause]
so let's take a look at the schedule
tomorrow
so here in Los Angeles 1 a.m so it
really is just tomorrow
um in Tokyo um it's already the 12th in
Tokyo but uh five o'clock tonight is
when the demo drops
all right so we're already less than 24
hours away
um and players will be able to start
downloading but they may not be able to
start downloading at the exact moment uh
the downloads started
all right and so but we have this
magical switch that when it becomes the
right time we press this magical switch
and then all of the magic happens and
all of the demos go down into the
servers it may take a couple minutes for
your download to start so if you get
online at one o'clock in the morning
we're like where is it where's my demo
don't worry calm down one two ten
minutes it'll be ready
all right so now that we know when it's
coming we want to know what's going to
be in the demo
all right allow me to explain
[Applause]
this is
so first off the demo allows you to
start a new game of Final Fantasy 16 and
play the opening prologue as is
and of course the save data can be
carried over to the full game so you'll
be able to continue your journey where
you left off on June 22nd it is
all right
um it's gonna be great for you guys to
get into the game and see what we have
in store for you but the story of Final
Fantasy 6 seen through this opening
prologue is
because this is the prologue um again
it's a little bit over the two hours of
gameplay um it's gonna be a little bit
heavy on cutscenes because we're talking
we're introducing the story to so you're
going to learn about the world and
you're going to learn about what drives
Clive
so once you complete uh the opening
prologue that will unlock a second uh
portion of the demo
um
so once you clear that opening it will
unlock a special battle demo available
from the title screen
foreign
and so because Clive um is still young
at the beginning of the story he is very
limited in what type of actions and
abilities that he has and so we wanted
to give you a better feel of what the
combat is going to be like later in the
game and that's what this battle demo is
foreign
and so numer abilities
um numerous abilities that are only
usable later in the game have been
unlocked in this demo so players can
experience the frenetic combat featured
in the game and what we really were
aiming for with the combat of Final
Fantasy XV
um players will be able to play this
content over and over and so we want you
to get a feel of the abilities and find
out what fits best for you the timely
accessories will also be there to let
you try out which ones you like and
which ones you don't need it's all there
okay and so we want to to know just one
thing that the area in this combat demo
is a very dark dark stronghold that also
takes place in the night so it is one of
the darkest areas in the game and so
don't go in thinking man Final Fantasy
16 everything is so dark I can't say
it's okay it's only this level and
actually it's not even that dark you can
think of this demo as kind of like a
test
um how dark can Final Fantasy 16 be
all right again this demo is due to be
released starting tomorrow at 1am La
time and so we hope you enjoy your first
steps into the world of Alistair
we finally able to get that off our
chests and talk about the demo
but
we've forgotten one thing
[Music]
[Applause]
right here right here what about this
right here
Togo big announcement yeah
[Applause]
um
all right so as you know this is Torgo
you know protagonist Clive sees his
bestest bestest partner
um a lot of people think he's a dog is
actually a wolf
um but and we found that he's very very
popular even though the game's not even
out Toro has already become one of the
most popular characters in the series
because he's so cuddly uh
and so um we've had people from around
the world said when are we gonna get to
buy toggle take my money and so we
worked hard with the merchandising team
and uh
group
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so starting today you can pre-order not
just the puppy but also the adult tour
but both are available today
[Applause]
um
all right and of course you know you can
pet turtle in the game as well but why
pet torgle only in the game when you can
pet him in real life
pre-order today
um
but in addition to the torgel plushies
we have a few more items to announce as
well
foreign
and personally I don't wear ear cuffs
that's why I had them make uh the
necklace but we do also sell the ear
cuffs
foreign
to the Final Fantasy 14 movies Maybe
[Applause]
these are all here and these are all
ready uh for pre-order play the game if
you fall in love with these characters
and these Goods um then it would be
great if you could also purchase them hi
[Music]
all right and so that's it with our big
announcement so let's wrap up the
opening and move on to the rest of the
panels
so stay
all right and first up is our battle
session with our director takaisan our
combat director suzuki-san and the
streamer Maximilian dude dude
[Applause]
it looks like um they're probably going
to be concentrating on fighting one of
the most difficult s-rank monsters in
the game so that should be fun
all right so please look forward to it
um
and so before we go um we did receive
one last special message from our friend
and the Japanese recording artist Kenji
yonisusan the singer of Final Fantasy
16's main theme song so please enjoy it
and we'll see you back soon
and it's against this
is
a
um
[Music]
foreign
reminder for those of you with tickets
the signing session will begin outside
shortly
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the harm to it goes to the lifting
at your Legend adorable
so also you all know that I will be
playing the demo
at 1am today yes
maybe I don't know
maybe I don't know find him what good
news okay let me remember how to play
lend me your strength
if I'm on square and it's YouTube
channel oh my gosh I gotta look good I
gotta do good combat
all right so I'm Titan right now
it's not like the good old days it's not
like the good old days it's not like the
girls
stop parroting everything instead drink
a Red Bull and think for yourselves
since when do you dictate what we do
exactly you're not the force of us power
to the people
oh well
Duality often complicates things
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
so what is everyone most excited for for
this game other than experiencing an
amazing story and playing Amazing
content
and having amazing combat I'm just
taking my time because you know I can't
believe I'm playing this game right now
the PC release
yeah the six of the 14 crew is wonder
I'm wearing by the way like I'm wearing
my 14 necklace because you know same
team got a support go support 14. well
we found the Imperial Garrison
so these are what the items look like
which is really cool so if you see
something shiny then pick it up all the
time
yes because I um I think I wanna I think
was the Pax panel yoship mentioned maybe
I'm not sure if it was packed I forgot
which one but that'll be super exciting
torgle is a male but he precious boy we
must have we must have twerkle baby
minion
I'm excited to dodge boilers for the
next X years oh
oh
damn it
they're everywhere
all right changing icons is L2 and then
the icons have their cooldown
Summoners Summit Aesthetics uh right now
I this is the demo like the combat demo
so I have access to multiple summons
that you probably will not have when the
game comes out like during this part of
the game because I should not be having
all of these icons
all right we've got Phoenix
foreign
because you get like magic and
um
magic and normal attack so you can
combine them to get better Combos and
better scores because you all know that
there's gonna be score stuff
oh yes torgel I think you can pre-order
the torgel they just announced I think
it's about for the subs also um
oh I have oh I do thank you for telling
me thank you
I want that off
I got it
done threatening was a good time
or basically a magical attack which
apparently we just have fired up
hello my friends
welcome in hello angel what you're on
the Square Enix YouTube channel for real
you all know the target
okay okay
success
I said Focus wyvern
I've ate four times
oh I'm I'm dodging a little early but he
scared me
toe
can you tell me how to Target first
y'all the world of Final Fantasy 16. I'm
dodging too early Final Fantasy 16 is
the latest in song
with the fusion of real-time action and
RPG features Final Fantasy 16 has been
developed as the first true action RPG
in the series okay
using the power of the PlayStation 4 to
its fullest the game delivers an
expenses what is my experience which we
liken to a high-speed roller coaster
rides
Hip Hop
good
two pieces of Texas toast and one side
of top surprise yeah not to brag but
we're like really good at math Sonic 399
grilled cheese now burger and pop Steel
you all know the target she was
dominated
Focus wiven
[Music]
thank you again
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
thank you
[Music]
you all know the target
shiva's dominant
and only the dominant
Focus wyvern
survivors is very unique to this
mission's success intuitive
yes sergeant
test
I said Focus wyvern
[Music]
okay
allow me to welcome you to the world of
Final Fantasy 16.
Final Fantasy XV is the latest
installment in the Final Fantasy series
a story for 35 years of History yes well
this is the 16th Mainline title in the
series there's absolutely no need for
any of the previous games before jumping
raising the power of the PlayStation 5
to its fullest the game delivers an
expansive thrilling gameplay experience
which we liken to a high speed roller
coaster ride
foreign
[Music]
okay sorry I got a little excited
ah
boy what's up
I'm peeking my mic I'm so sorry I'm so
excited you all know the target
shiva's dominated
focus of wyvern
I said Focus why but
[Music]
allow me to welcome you to the world of
Final Fantasy 16.
Final Fantasy 16 is the latest
installment of the final fantasy series
a storied franchise with 35 years of
History yet while this is the 16th
Mainline title in the series there's
absolutely no need to have played any of
the previous games before jumping in
with the fusion of real-time action and
RPG features Final Fantasy 16 has been
developed as the first true action RPG
in the series we're getting that timing
down using the power of the PlayStation
5 to its fullest the game delivers an
expansive thrilling gameplay experience
for True lichen to a high-speed roller
coaster ride
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
combat director ryota Suzuki and content
creator Maximilian dude
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Final Fantasy 16 no main direct
hello everyone as you know I am
hiroshitakai main director for Final
Fantasy 16.
[Applause]
and I am the combat director for Final
Fantasy 16.
hi everyone uh my name is Maximilian
dude and uh I'm a content creator and
I'm lucky enough to be joined by
takaisan and suzuki-san today on stage
and uh I'm just a big fan of action
games fighting games things with combat
good to see you all here
okay just before just before we go I
want to let you know that we have a lot
of fans watching in Japan so we're gonna
have the lovely Ellen here to help us
out with translation from English to
Japanese
[Applause]
um
foreign
[Applause]
and I myself love action games I love 2D
fighting games and I love your videos
watch them all the time
that means the world just knowing that
devs are out there paying attention to
content creators alike there's a
relationship there uh that's really
special so uh since a lot of you guys
have seen my content you know I'm into
things like fighting games action games
action RPGs and I have a special
admiration for how the combat in all of
these games plays out and from
everything that we've seen so far in the
videos and trailers for Final Fantasy 16
some of my favorite bits have been
watching one-on-one combat with other
human enemies and seeing how they react
we see a Dragoon fight in some
situations in other moments we've seen a
forest where there's like a Ninja really
cool moves uh those are easily some of
my favorite moments we've seen of Final
Fantasy 16 so far
foreign
no matter what type of enemy you're
gonna fight in you're gonna find a lot
of different experiences depending on
what you fight I think we have something
really special
[Music]
are you guys I mean for the combat and
we tried to create something that was
not only exciting for the people playing
but also going to be visually stunning
for the people watching
yeah and I think from everything we've
seen so far that is front stage in the
center of the whole game is the action
spectacle of it all but I'm really
curious uh this is kind of a deviation
of a lot of like Mainline RPGs that is
not turn based it is focused on action
what were some of the key moments or key
gameplay things you guys really wanted
to hit when you were approaching this
with a bigger action Focus
foreign
controllers
directions
so first and foremost when we're
designing this combat system is that we
wanted to bring in you know as many
players to the final fantasy series and
to this full-time action experience as
possible um and so we looked towards
um you know action games out there what
do action game players want in their
games and we wanted to create something
um that felt good
um and felt you're getting direct
feedback from the controller and
something that feels very visceral and
very direct and that's what we wanted to
create
foreign
again it's very important about how that
combat feels and so we wanted to create
something that felt really really good
and so we focus a lot of our development
on that
um we also focused on making the system
fully customizable because we know that
there are a lot of different players out
there and we know that there's going to
be a lot of different play Styles and a
lot of different combinations so we
wanted to make something that's fully
customizable so that players can put
together combinations that maybe we
didn't even think of
yeah that sounds really exciting I think
everything that you're looking for from
an action game is that degree of
customization being able to go in and
tailor your own play style to what the
game is presenting you
um
[Music]
hi
um because Final Fantasy 16 you know
it's our first time going into this
real-time action we wanted to create
something that again was going to be
really exciting for Action players but
we also realized that you know there are
a lot of Final Fantasy fans out there
that aren't um that good at action games
that aren't that familiar with action
games so we wanted to create something
that felt good for them as well and
create this system that felt very
balanced and I felt like it was for
everyone and I think that we've um
really done that and we hope that um
through Final Fantasy 16 we've created a
game that can bring fans you know maybe
that didn't like action games and learn
to love action games through Final
Fantasy 16.
yeah for sure I'm really looking forward
to eventually getting our hands on the
game and trying out some stuff because
if there's one thing I love about action
games is a challenge
foreign
we haven't really had the time to show
combat in depth for a long period of
time so we'd really like to do that here
for you guys today
so you guys ready
ah
[Applause]
um
all right so uh for those players uh and
people here that haven't been able to
watch um the state of play yet we
recently revealed um the hunt system
um where players can visit this hunt
board to gain information on Marx
foreign
so by visiting the hunt board in the
Hideaway players can gain information on
marks that are terrorizing the land that
need to be slain and go out and search
them and slay them
hi um
[Music]
all right and so um on the hunt board
these notorious marks all have different
kinds of ranks from rank C being the
bottom all the way up to rank s so uh
Max
what do you want to try out
uh yeah okay so
that's rank is pretty high
um and I'm I'm thinking this sounds kind
of exciting you guys want to see some
crazy fights and yeah
all right so I am nowhere close to the
level of the developers uh on the game
but I will give it my best before we do
this we talked about customization uh do
we have an opportunity to set up icon
powers and moves
all right we'll let you customize just
this time though all right let's bring
up the game screen
[Applause]
all right so we have multiple icons
unlocked for you here and you can pick
the ones you'd like in your Loadout in
the abilities uh the gear and icons menu
yeah I think uh so my whole goal is to
kill this creature before it kills me
[Applause]
foreign foreign
I think I'm also going to try aerial
blast I I think this is where we're
going this one has a lot of damage
Associated I believe
Anthony
so you're choosing all of the strongest
attacks yeah
okay
full berserk
classes
that's right and uh what I did also
notice is that certain abilities can
actually be mixed and matched so when
you I believe you find a Mastery of an
ability you're allowed to put that on
something that might not normally allow
it for example we have Titan here I am
going to put judgment Bowl
I'll still have the blocks
I know
foreign
s you've channeled those three icons and
then mastered the fourth icons best
attack and so now you have the best
attacks of four icons on three
okay yeah okay okay we see what you're
doing you gave me too much power
customer is
I mean I guess this is one way to do it
I mean you're going all out we'll see
how he does
I mix and matched one more lightning rod
is always a very fun ability in this
game I need some I think I'm gonna need
some range so uh yeah I think we are
ready to go up against this hunt should
we back out from here and talk to the
Moogle hi
um
all right um yeah so let's just uh let
everyone see what the hunt board
actually looks like let's talk to the
Moogle
he's so cute considering how dangerous
this is about to be
here
all right so when you open the hunt
board it looks like this you will see uh
the billets
um showing the different notorious marks
that are out there I see you're on an S
rank run here
I mean it looks like you're ready for
the S rank you're not gonna even I I
think I would disappoint so many people
if we didn't go immediately to the
hardest most difficult thing
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay you can bring the screen back up
that's okay
here we go
see if he can find the mark
go straight out of the village
I was about to say I think it's up to us
to figure out where these creatures are
it didn't immediately pinpoint it is
yeah I mean you know we don't have much
time here today so we're kind of skip
that we'll tell you where this one is
thank you
right so this area that we currently see
you can see it's kind of foggy today but
this is at this point of the game it's
foggy here normally it's uh much the
skies are much blue
yeah
I mean if you're tired of running you
could always ride a chocobo I can press
the R3 button okay yeah okay
[Applause]
don't bother with any of those other
monsters just go I'll do my best
turn right yeah there we go
around okay okay
we entered the land of spoilers
foreign
so you can see those ruins in the
distance there that's where we're going
yes yeah okay
it's getting a bit spooky out here I'm
just making a note that it's getting
scary the closer we get
um
I mean so um your head currently you're
in an abandoned Village I mean you can
probably figure out why um it's been
abandoned awesome
almost there almost there and stop stop
in the back
yes
I'm assuming that's our Target right
there that's your target
that Target
I need moral support
[Applause]
I feel only slightly better okay are we
ready are we ready for this is everybody
are we good
all right
the plan is to live as long as possible
I mean try your best
my apologies if I don't talk I'm gonna
be concentrating foreign
level 30.
um the level of Atlas is 45 so this is a
big difference in level here so this is
a very very difficult battle
oh
[Applause]
the big attacks have cooldowns so um you
watch those cooldowns and when you can
use them again use them again
oh
corella
um
oh
yo um
this Max guy is pretty good
oh you had to say something
[Applause]
so Final Fantasy 16 has a Parry system
so if you time your attack at the moment
that the enemy attacks you will get that
Perry and then you'll be able to deal uh
even more damage but it's very very
risky
oh nice
chance
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
they go down to uh
and it's down that the damage that you
deal while staggered is displayed at the
end of the Stagger
so next is uh doing very good at dodging
these attacks that's why it's surviving
for so long that's a very good strategy
is
[Laughter]
I say use his limit break
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
does a lot of damage in this game so you
want it when you want to finish a battle
quickly that's what you use
[Music]
I'm sorry about the dog
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of course
um as the enemies hit points go down the
enemy starts you know doing some pretty
unfair attacks so we'll see what happens
oh
[Applause]
you can do this
oh my God
[Applause]
oh nice
I'd like to warn everyone I'm getting
close to having no healing
oh no oh nice oh
[Music]
foreign
God I see
Joseph so I I really tried there
[Music]
that losses I think 15 levels above
where we're currently at at this point
in the game but yeah I would I would
love to know if uh suzuki-san possibly
take can you show me a thing or two is
it is it possible we can get developers
to to at least I'd love to see how they
play it differently than me
I know
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
they had a a video where I did this
battle and um I lost
and uh so I think I want some Redemption
yeah
[Applause]
I say let's do this then
hi okay let's turn on okay
all right yeah so somebody bring me a
beer I'm ready to uh
here we go
funny if he lost here too huh
so I'm gonna I'm refrain from speaking
now so
I'm really curious to see the
differences in play Styles like I was
going for an all-out
crazy damage
and I'm already seeing some nice
defensive stuff
foreign
I believe Titan has many physical
counters uh which is always fun in
action games when you can switch an
enemies attack to being something as
beneficial for you yeah
nice
[Music]
foreign
and so what you saw there is he uses the
Phoenix uh ability heat wave to cancel
out the magic and then counter with
three attacks
and so yeah that was the counter as well
we've got lots of counter type of
attacks um for this game as well just
like you said I'm already seeing several
things I had no idea existed yeah
I'm seeing the biggest difference in
game plan he's doing a lot of whale
damage to eventually get them on the
ground to do more damage right
now
so yeah when an enemy gets staggered
that's when you want to deal with most
damage because your damage goes up
you can see he's not saying he's very
very nervous right now
so yeah I mean you know we're in front
of it we can't we can't yeah it's here
we gotta impress the that's actually a
counter attack I had no idea
oh
I'd like to note how difficult this is
he's been working this creature and it's
at 50 percent health
[Applause]
oh
yeah
guys
and again it's that level difference
right there he's got that 15 levels also
he's only wearing level 30 gear so his
gear is going to be weaker as well
oh
my God
wow
[Applause]
so when you get good that's stagger
damage you can get that up
okay
I love when you have to internally keep
in mind all of your abilities and if
they're available when you eventually
stagger the enemy
um
foreign
there's lots of different ways maybe
even ways that we as the developers
haven't thought of yet so
um
[Music]
I see that attack and I'm getting
horrible flashbacks now
that was close
ah
[Applause]
oh yeah
foreign
[Applause]
will give you that extra damage oh is he
done
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
revenge and leveled up
okay
I mean one of the great things about
Final Fantasy 16 is that you know we
have a level difference of 15 here
that's a great level difference but
depending on the player's skill it's
still something that's able to do so I
mean that's what's one of the cool
things about Final Fantasy 16.
you know I think what I like the most
about it is the difference in play style
I saw some really defensive stuff that
is actually incredibly cool looking
counters Perry's magic counters seeing
all that play out in front of me is like
I think I'm gonna be running that when
it comes out
foreign
um but you really surprised us with your
play today Max we actually didn't think
you were going to be able to do that
well today you did an awesome job
thank you thank you guys so much I tried
my best I just wanted to survive uh but
really the the pleasure is being able to
share this stage with such incredible
people so thank you guys a ton for this
is
and thank you from us as well we were
very honored to be on the stage with you
thank you
hi um
all right so that's the end of our stage
here today um where it's time for us to
take another short break but please stay
tuned for Alana pierce my hero-san for
our story and lore panel coming up next
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
reminder for those of you with tickets a
photo session will begin outside shortly
[Music]
foreign
like for those that don't play uh action
games that often
I kind of want to start it over but I
don't know how to do it the right way so
I'm just gonna leave it
says something about taking her down
[Applause]
really better eating stuff ma'am your
tushy
oh I didn't even upgrade any abilities I
didn't check this stuff I was just in
awe that I was still playing
hi Leon
this time all right
oh well that stagger real fast
oh where's she going
please
nowhere to go
can I hit you oh Jesus okay no I cannot
hit her
you know it's actually nice to see the
uh Timeless Dodge thing can I go back
here
because then I'll know
when I don't have them on
can I hit it oh I guess magic helps
uh this I don't know how far the demo oh
my gosh there's a lot happening I know
once you beat the first two hours of the
game you get the demo uh so then when
you get the combat trial which I believe
also includes this
I'm like I keep thinking that's a quick
time but it's just the excess uh the
accessory stuff and so I'm like wait is
[Music]
yes
oh
[Music]
I don't have a follow or anything but
thank you so much for that's all
cinebag Clash oh this is the button
mashing thing or not button math with
the matching machine
Korea your nails
oh
all right
I was like was this is this the stopping
point here
uh-huh
okay
I don't want to get in trouble so I'm
just checking every time something
happens
oh thank you welcome welcome
yeah cause this this is the one where
they're like I'll tap you and you play
too much
so I want to make sure
thank you
you're nothing
and I will not
let you standing my way
are you older
moment okay
well rest in peace what
laughs
this feels like I was like is she sure
that I'm supposed to continue to play
this because
I feel like I have like a treat
I guess it's probably like right after
we finish off Garuda for real this time
okay uh oh my God the music sounds so
good
[Music]
uh uh a big point a big boy
oh I did not Dodge I'll have fireballs
[Music]
Kittery for owl I'm just kidding I'm
sorry man
well
I guess he was gonna try and attack me
oh man I wish I would have realized I
had the had the accessory on
foreign
[Music]
because you have the first two hours I
will carry over and then you unlock
combat demo
is what I'm currently doing now
I believe
oh I can Clash with the magic that's
pretty sick
as an important go ahead first do it I
don't know
look if it has a big old Noggin
I'm ready to push whatever button you
tell me to
smashing
[Music]
really she's about to do something I'm
not ready for her yep
stopper ow ow ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am
they asking me in front of Champs
oh I punished sir
maybe I'm being too defensive maybe I
should just go at it like am I supposed
to stop her from doing this or I'm gonna
I don't think I'm gonna die
oh
yeah
I don't I I think I'm gonna die
how am I supposed to dodge that
quite I mean if we I'm dead am I dead am
I dead oh my God I have no health I'm
dead
[Music]
no I know how to dodge it I'm like
asking like how do I dodge it
because it looked like a whole full
screen AOE
oh I see it I see I see I see it I see
it I'm supposed to just just back away
okay I'm supposed to be back here okay
okay that's the last time we're gonna
hit by that I promise
this stuff not so much I'll probably
still get by it
well she cornered me
uh Clive get out of there I think I
don't know
oh I'm a liar
I got hit by it again
better
but this is all new to me okay I don't
know what's happening
I'm just gonna stay away from her she's
hurting me and I'm sad
I'm just gonna see
you look pretty from afar no you're
you're doing amazing sweetie
but I wanna I wanna attack her
all right I'm going in I'm going in as
soon as I get in she's gonna do the AOE
isn't she
the reading wide
okay it looks like she's parking I want
to figure this out no she's not parking
I'm really far away I'm being very
cautious
oh wait did you wait look at this detail
I walk by the trees and I burn them
because I need trees what the heck
little goodbye tree okay
[Music]
that's so late
all right we're getting we're getting
some attacks
[Music]
I'm waiting for a button to pop up
there it is
[Music]
foreign
I would like my arm hello
in my face
[Music]
I got my arm back
thank you
yes Slammer
cheese
[Music]
oh my God
oh we're doing Hellfire she's a daughter
now
goodbye Karina it's been real
now it's here okay cool
um
all right this is the stopping point uh
I am
yeah thank you so much Square Enix and
thank you all for hanging out with me
today
um the demo is available tomorrow you
can unlock this stuff after you do the
demo
um so you have to do the story part
um oh thank you
um you have to do the
um you have the first two hours and once
the first two hours are done that
carries over to the main game which
releases next week and then you can
unlock some of the combat stuff because
right now what I just did like how I've
had abilities that you weren't um you
weren't
you weren't allowed to do it no that is
I am done we are done no more no
spoilies no more spoilies we're just
showcasing combat today but yeah again
thank you guys so much for hanging out I
got a sign off of my Twitch account on
this computer so nobody else takes over
my life
but yes I'm so excited it's a week a
week but I will be streaming the story
portion of the demo probably after you
guys already do it so you will probably
won't have spoilers I'll probably do it
uh on Wednesday it'll be a little late
I'm a little I've been busy but yeah
thank you guys so much for hanging out
foreign
[Music]
let's go
America
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to the stage localization director
Michael Christopher Cody Fox creative
director and original screenplay writer
kazatoya my hero and video game writer
and content creator Alana Pierce
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone how you doing
[Applause]
I don't know if we'll ever have a cool
intro than that in my entire life what a
beautiful voice
so hello everyone welcome I'm Alana
Pierce if you don't know me I'm a
content creator and video game writer at
Sony Santa Monica Studio is
I am the creative director and original
screenplay writer for Final Fantasy 16.
and again uh I am Koji Fox Michael
Christopher Koji Fox I've been stage all
night and I have with me papi turbo is
going to help me with uh the clicker for
uh the screen up here so
is
it worked amazing
uh
uh so what are we talking about today
um again we're here to talk about the
story and the lore about Final Fantasy
16 but again we're gonna try not to
spoil anything again that we already
haven't spoiled
Koto
was
that would be a very bad idea this close
to launch I think everybody in this room
would be very upset with us
um
so yeah I mean we've released a lot of
information on 16 so far but I like to
think that you know the main story and
what we've got in store is still quite a
mystery so we hope it's still a mystery
at the end of this panel
um
is that
is that is
that help oh no no no no the voice of
Sidney
[Applause]
security is he drunk
no [__] no he said
okay
uh
well if it's okay I'd love to ask you
about some questions about the story
okay of course I
so we've heard of or I've seen online at
least a few comparisons uh to Game of
Thrones there's definitely like kind of
a dark fantasy vibe going on do you
agree with those comparisons and if so
in what ways
yeah I mean Game of Thrones is a
fantastic piece of fantasy and I'm a fan
myself I think the most significant
inspiration we took from it was in terms
of art Direction
is
[Music]
and you know as you all know Game of
Thrones is a work of fantasy but and
that means it has these really unique
character designs these unique settings
and world but at the same time they all
feel like they could exist in real life
and that's throughout the whole of the
series everything is sort of really
directed with this great balance and
keeping it all together
and you know this might look quite easy
but it's actually super difficult to
achieve it's because it's a real case of
balance and as soon as that balance gets
thrown off people watching people
reading are going to think there's
something not quite right here and as
soon as that gets into their head it's
going to completely break immersion
foreign
was achieve something similar with that
really high level of immersion and
that's the way we've approached it from
the story game design through to levels
even the background music we really want
to create this immersive world
but of course 16 story is its own unique
story it is the tale of Clive rossfield
um
and of course there will be political
aspects there will be some moral
quandries within the story but first and
foremost it's just a real focused
narrative on Clive rossfield story
um but yeah I mean I wouldn't say though
that Game of Thrones gets to lay Soul
claim to all of the CD brothels and evil
mothers and brutal beheadings uh in
fantasy
Game of Thrones
[Music]
but that said um we did use Game of
Thrones television series as kind of a
guideline for how we're going to
approach
um the level of and tone of dialogue uh
in the game we wanted to do something
that was fantasy and felt really fantasy
but was not going to alienate users that
weren't really familiar
um with that older type of English which
is more attributed to Fantasy literature
I mean Game of Thrones had this really
good balance of authenticity mixed with
this maturity and also kind of
familiarity that ultimately ended up
feeling both really dramatic and as well
as accessible and we wanted to emulate
that I mean it has that feeling of you
know when they say something you'll be
like oh that's something that maybe I
would say if I lived in that time
I know so moving on from Game of Thrones
uh the game spans three decades of
Clive's life the protagonist of course
what can we expect from these different
time periods and
um
so you know as I mentioned in my
previous answer 16 is the story of Clive
rossfield is
and by taking these three different time
periods so his privileged teenage years
his revenge driven 20s and his 30s where
he's experienced a little bit more and
sort of has that under his belt by
depicting these three different eras in
Clive's life we're able to show you you
know how his life progresses and how
valistia changes from his perspective
and through his eyes
and of course as you move through these
different time periods the world itself
will change and there will also be all
kinds of encounters and partings with
different characters waiting for you in
each one
I mean ultimately Final Fantasy 16 is
about finding what exactly it is that
drives Clive how he navigates through
this kind of periods of self-loathing
and then self-discovery and then
ultimately how he comes to accept
himself and his role in the world
finding oneself is not something that
usually happens in a day or a day and a
half 40 hours of gameplay
um it's something that takes you know um
years it's driven by a lifetime of
experience and encounters and to make
that progression feel very natural
um the only reasonable course was to
stretch the story out over multiple
periods of Clive's life foreign
something that I know the team has done
to make it easier for players to
actually track all of Clive's
relationships throughout this course of
time is active time long
um this is something in the game that is
can be activated during cutscenes and
it'll tell you who's who what's
happening with them how you're related
to them it I can't think of many games
that have done this uh how did you come
up with the idea and how do you feel it
will help play this is
foreign
so I have a question for you guys have
you ever been playing a game watching a
film watching some TV and then this
character comes up and you're like oh no
who's that guy or the scene changes and
you're like wait where is this no anyone
have that
so no Pokemon
um
yeah I get that all the time
and you know if you keep trying to play
or keep trying to watch but you just
have that question gnawing away at you
it really takes you out it ruins the
immersion and it's just constantly on
your mind right
now
and so we put this active time law
system into the game because I thought
wouldn't it be great if you could just
resolve that question inside the game
itself
dick
s
so active time law gives you access to
lots of information in the game but it
doesn't give you access to all
information at all times
it selects the information that's most
important to the player at that moment
in time so for example if you call it up
during a cut scene it might give you the
information on the characters that are
actually appearing and if you call it up
when you're playing in a particular
location it might give you information
on where you are at that point in time
and so that means that you can just look
up the information that you want to know
straight in the game and then jump
straight back into playing so I think
that it should really help out players
in that sense and no spoilers
foreign
[Laughter]
law in the state of play you guys
briefly showed us a few in-game
characters I thought would be very cool
in regard to keeping up with what's
going on in the story and the law
16 we have these two great characters
um you see up on the screen we have our
lordsmen Hippocrates and we have uh
Vivian Ninetales who help out
um with the game's lore
it might be biased but I love the hair
color
so again no spoilers I'm not going to
ask you for the fullback stories
um but can you tell us what their
function is and how you think they'll
help players
so both Vivian and the Hippocrates are
available to tell players more about the
world of Final Fantasy 16 whenever
there's something they want to know
so let's talk a little bit about
Hippocrates first uh his name is a
little bit of a mouthful but here's a
lovely and kind Gent
s
so Hippocrates is someone who researches
the history and customs of balestier and
when Clive comes back from his
adventures and tells him about what he's
seen and heard Hippocrates will note
that down in his records
and for example he'll make a note of
everything that appears in the active
time law system we were just discussing
so you don't need to worry about missing
anything in the Heat of the Moment
and we had a little bit of a video
earlier showing you this but as you give
him more and more information about
balestier hypocrisy Hippocrates will
level up and when he does he'll also
discover new law for you that you can
uncover that way
so if there's anyone out there who's
interested in learning more about Laura
in the world of Valencia I really
recommend that you speak to him very
often
all right and so my Hassan talked a
little bit about Hippocrates so I'll
talk a little bit about Vivian Ninetales
um so while Hippocrates is more of an
expert on uh dalastia's past
um
Vivian is more in tune with what's going
on
currently what's happening now
and so Clive is a very busy man he's off
saving the world saving people doing all
of these different things
um but while he's doing all that a lot
of other stuff is happening in the very
large realm of Valencia and so he
doesn't always know what's going on so
he'll come back to the Hideaway um he'll
want to figure out what's going on he
can go to uh Vivian and Vivian will tell
him all about what's happening in the
other nations
and so Vivian will give you um this kind
of reports and these updates
um you can kind of compare it to
um the uh Brave story from Final Fantasy
Tactics
um but the one thing that's different is
is that with brave story was all text
and so um put a lot of you know uh the
read the player would have to read a lot
of stuff and we didn't want to have that
be a barrier for the players this time
so we wanted to make that a lot more
Visual and that means using lots of maps
um we have uh videos that she will show
you
um and also have that you saw that
wonderful kind of
you know the little circles with looks
like the you know the crazy person
looking to find out where the killer was
and have the all the strings attached um
that is something we also want to do
because we wanted to make it a very
visual experience
um so that you would look at it and know
exactly what was going on
probably the coolest thing about these
two characters is they're not just there
for the lord they're actually characters
that are in the game that are a part of
Clive's lives and have their own stories
as well so Clive will be able to learn
more about these two via these great
side quests to learn about what drives
them and what you know how they came to
be with Clive
assistant
um
I'm very excited to meet them they look
awesome
um there's some more stuff that you guys
showed in the state of play that I'm
also excited about one thing you showed
up with side quests I'm a big side quest
person I imagine everyone in this room
is too where Final Fantasy is concerned
uh I mean it just helps us get immersed
in the world and learn more about what's
going on even outside of these two
characters so what can players expect
from the side quests in this game and do
we get any bonuses or what kind of
experience do we get from doing side
quests is
[Music]
so there are lots of different ways to
approach making Quests for games and the
approach that we took for 16 was to
ensure that each and every Quest had a
proper story
foreign
s we've made sure to really put a story
around it so it's why are the Goblins
there why do you need to go and defeat
them and so by engaging with the side
quests players will be able to sort of
learn more about Valencia more about
what's going on and really engage with
that content there yeah
um
and we have of course made sure that
Quest placement has been done from a
game-wide overall perspective so they
won't be the side quests won't be there
getting in the way of the main story
they're there and they're available for
players to do when they want to take a
little bit of a breather yeah
and of course as as you mentioned
completing quests will get you Gale get
you experience points but it will also
earn Clive renown
yes
and the more Clive's renowned builds
he'll find that he gets donations from
people who support his cause and some of
those donations maybe items some of
those items may be quite rare
crystals
and depending on the quest there may be
some other ones as well that give you
sort of improvements and and upgrade
your your systems your skills your gear
like giving you more maximum number of
potions that can be held things like
that so I hope you'll all get there get
out there and enjoy playing lots of the
side quests
um but I think what is kind of important
is what my hero Honda said about how
these quests don't really get in the way
of the main scenario um while some
players want to learn everything they
can about the world myself being one of
those players some want to just focus
maybe on just the main story or want to
focus just on the action and not feel
like they're being like forced in this
into that psych content in order to
progress
and so we wanted to create
um you know this system that catered to
all those types of players
um and so while 50 or Final Fantasy 16's
content and that side contest is
intrically woven into the main scenario
and it supplements it and it enhances it
um skipping it will not affect your
ability to join the game and understand
that Central narrative although I do
recommend you play them because they're
really good question
foreign
I have one last question for you before
we have to go I think
maybe a complicated question what do you
think makes a final fantasy story
[Music]
because
so this isn't just applicable to Final
Fantasy but one of the things that I
think makes a really good story is
making sure that it doesn't break the
immersion
so for example
um if you're playing a game and the game
design and the scenario The Narrative
aren't aligned very well that could be
very jarring so for example if you're
playing it and the main character's
thoughts and feelings don't match up
with what the player feels that can
really take you out of it
and you know if you were really immersed
in this game and then all of a sudden
you find yourself taken out of it and
just completely can't get back into it
it sort of ruins the experience and some
people might just walk away stop playing
the game you know I'm sure that's
happened to lots of people here
and so what we've really aimed for with
Final Fantasy 16 is to create this story
this narrative experience where once you
pick up the controller you're not going
to be able to put it down again you're
not going to want to be able to put it
down
um and so to me that's what I really
think a good story and a good narrative
is
and you know with Final Fantasy 16 we've
really put our all in our hearts into
creating this so I really hope that
you'll all play the story enjoy it and
once you've got to the end of it you'll
let us know what you thought
um yeah
um I think that what is most important
in the game is that you know the
storytelling doesn't just take place in
the quests doesn't just take place in
that main scenario that it takes place
throughout the whole world and this is
I mean whether that means you know
random NPC chatter or maybe some signs
you know on stores or some books that
you find in a house
um lying about town or maybe on maps or
in letters or maybe even in like the
names of places that you see on a map
um or item help text
um valastia is full of tales Beyond just
clives
um there are you know tens of thousands
of people living in this realm and they
all have their own stories and we want
to put those stories in the game as well
so players can see that as well
um and they're there I mean we don't
push that on the player but if you look
you're gonna find that stuff
and one more thing that's about great
stories selling is you always got to
have some bad puns
it
is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
well thank you both so much and thank
you to everybody here
[Applause]
and to everybody on Twitch we appreciate
all of you as well um my last question
is for everybody in the room right now
I'll be excited to play Final Fantasy
16.
I think so
yeah
[Music]
I thank you so much for joining us
um okay so I think we're done yes but
we're not done with the panels we have
one more exciting panel coming up with
soaking and Alex talking about the sound
of Final Fantasy 16. so please wait a
little bit longer and we'll be right
back up here thanks thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
reminder reminder for those of you with
tickets the photo session will begin
outside shortly
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I gotta get used to dodging because my
Dodges are not very good
it's nice the music is so good you see
can you hear it like this is great oh my
God this is so exciting
okay I'm probably getting really hurt
aren't I yeah
I forgot about fire I need to use fire
what's up
[Music]
nice okay okay
okay
I'm trying come on come on
yeah we did it oh yeah
[Music]
thanks
okay so now we're supposed to press new
game that's that's the next step
I'm on the official channel oh no I'm
not don't say that don't say that wait
what what are you talking about no I'm
not
I'm on the official Square in extreme
Jonathan stop recording me there I'm on
the stream wait what where that's so
cool I didn't know they were gonna put
me on their stream
no you can keep okay all right so now
we're gonna press a new game hi hi I'm
on screen extreme hi hello I didn't know
I was going to be on it that's what I
nice okay cool
whoa oh my God it looks so beautiful to
report my lady
you just hear them
have them lead Sid and his little pet to
the chapel
I shall entertain them there
whoa It's so
it's so much you've come for me after
all
she's so pretty
I won the mainstream what the heck
that's pretty cool though
the holy Empire
oh okay this is older Clive
oh the dog oh sorry wolf
the hot dog wolves
headwind
s do you guys see there's gonna be merch
oh I'm so excited okay okay
um finding your way should you find
yourself lost do not friend hold down L3
and trust your animal instinct to point
to in the right direction your current
destination will be displayed okay hold
on L3
oh [__] oh so oh that's so cool
sure whoa
oh
what
what happened here oh that's so cool
um
oh I can't I can't see hold on something
about a slight technical difficulty here
I don't
if something happened I don't know what
it just like stops
it was on earlier
it's probably because I'm on this I was
[Music]
oh game froze yeah hold on
oh someone else had the same thing
happen to them okay okay
yeah I mean you know it'll get fixed in
a sec I'm sure
cool thank you so much that's okay okay
we're good we're fixed okay
[Music]
foreign
this is so cool
they're all that big
are you gonna give up
oh my God the music
[Music]
Jonathan just showed me on the scoring
extreme
hi everyone I didn't know I was going to
be on the screening stream but that's
really cool hello
I'm Sarah key
I like Final Fantasy and Kingdom Hearts
all right uh making an effort some large
Gates and stiff lovers require extra
effort to operate use x to access them
then hold R2 to push or pull with all
your minds okay
okay
got it
foreign
I am loving this so far I cannot wait
for the full game oh my God I'm so
excited
it doesn't even feel real to be playing
it honestly
okay oh oops my bad
I felt like I was crouched was I
crouched
I don't know unfortunately
it's so cool to have a final fantasy in
medieval times again
so epic
[Music]
yeah
oh my God this is sick dude why is
[__] staggered him wait how do I do
that again
I think this
second toggle yeah
this is amazing the combat's so smooth
too
the Spells really light up right right
oh my goodness you guys not this time I
met some of the Square Enix um and
they're just so humble and so nice like
Jay Catherine man there's so many people
like Sunil there's
Derek
lots of people
and everyone is just let's get them
[Music]
yeah
oh [__] oops oh this time oh my God
[Music]
thank you
oh this time
this time almost checked
keep on
it's a friendly finally yes I finally
met Caleb hey hey here oh I love you
guys too
they announced the Platinum Games yeah I
saw that I saw that's amazing
Yuna on Square Enix Channel wait what
wait am I actually on their Channel no
I'm not
oh okay am I did they catch me talking I
hope I didn't swear
yeah
wait I'm not still on it am I oh
yes okay let's go
let's go okay I don't know where I'm
supposed to go this is embarrassing
oh there you go
there were one for half measures were
you Benedict heck yeah let's go guys
treasure chest
all right
anything else here
can I jump over I guess I can't
let's go upstairs
I'm not a famous streamer get out of
here guys
you guys make me feel free all because
of you guys
oh yeah let's go well guarded
basic uh basic abilities such as burning
blade
okay
seems they were expecting we don't say
oh man
[Music]
oh my God guys this is so gorgeous like
the colors
[Music]
guys it's not a dog it's a wolf you know
I keep calling it doggo
okay we can still call it doggle right
oh yeah
can I use my sofa
get him
oh there it is
over here
more enemies you're kidding dog wolf
please tell me you can turn off the
blade chat spam
yeah boy
oh man yeah
get him
all the voices Oh you mean like when
they keep saying stuff that they're
using
there might be an option
you know what though guys this is like
really friendly for people who get
motion sickness like I'm not getting
this I'm getting zero motion sickness
from this it's perfect and you guys know
how sensitive I am
[Music]
is that it we're done can we go now
or two
use L2 and r2s as well
so you have to hold this down
[Music]
silken and Alex in less than half an
hour okay perfect
hey Zen how are you what the hell
happened here
oh yeah they look so good
a little light for prayer isn't it
do I seem so desperate as to corroville
at the feet of a false god she's she's
definitely gorgeous
I was waiting she's yeah yeah she's
gorgeous not for too long I hope yeah
she's sexy he's sexy he's sexy they're
all I'll wish for a midnight shots
thank you for the thank you for the
gifted Subs guys
where are the men and women you took
from lost wing
we shall be requiring a Services
indefinitely
thank you Chloe
hey Ice tiger think of all the things we
can create together
the world that we can build
you need me
your king needs oh no they're all hot
they're building a new world
just not his that bastard's danger is
Twisted as his promises are false
and I want no part of it King Barnabas
saved you and this is how you speak of
him
what
to a leader who'd use me
like he uses you
you know nothing of me said office
you're right
I don't know who you are anymore
or what you want
dude they look so good I only know what
you're so happy for you you're not
excited I'm oh I'm happy you guys get to
play the demo tonight
so what changed
holy [__] thank you
you guys thank you I use my talents to
my advantage and you would tell me there
is shame in that if there's no shame
then why do you feel so sorry arousing
thank you Commander
I feel sorry for it it's you
it's you
I can't do this anymore
oh our nails are all yellow too
oh wait what if you would stand between
our leash and his dream
then you leave me no choice
yo what's happening right now
wait what wait I'm supposed to play this
part right
I'm supposed to play with her right I
can play this
yeah the Garuda yeah yeah
wait
[Music]
holy [__]
oh my God this is nuts man
all right
dude what is happening
this is sick
yeah yeah
oh my God
oh this is so sick
[Applause]
right
I'm trying not to talk so much during
these cutscenes sorry guys I want you
guys to listen
finish them
finish
[Music]
oh sick what at least it's not three
against one
yo man I'm gonna die of this [__] I'm
only gonna die
I don't know if I did or no I'm gonna
heal yeah
oh yeah
wait what
[Music]
when the screen flashes red like this is
going to press R1
oh my God
yo what
is it press wait when screen flashes
blue
[Music]
Square before oh like oh there oh sick
okay I want to see this
oh my God
oh my God that [__] abilities insane
wait why didn't I just hit this because
it was staying here already
foreign
say hi
Mike is right here
say hi hi let the camera's here if you
want to see them all right yeah yeah
man Caleb's here
[Music]
dude this is insane man even though I
probably suck at this game
oh God I need to heal
[Music]
I'm trying to figure out okay
it's a Char drop that's why I can't use
it okay I'm getting this now
sick
dude
my attacks here
dude so much is going on I'm like
[Music]
staggered yo I didn't know there was
staggering in this game Caleb
well I didn't see a lot of it I like
wanted it to be a surprise
[Music]
she doesn't look happy Togo come on
trying to figure out
oh yeah I love that
boy
get him get him get him it's almost dead
get it get it get it get it
oh yeah sick all this time
dead
oh guys I'm like sweating
you and I throw a left elbow
I killed it
Mega Man X you want a speedrune
thanks for the gifted Subs guys
level up ding
sorry if I missed chat guys
look at you living your best life
you're gonna make me cry
I miss you guys too hi Kushina yeah
Caleb's here you guys say hi
okay
oh
cutscene
oh wait
I said are you all right
hey Ella how's it going
thank you
wait is this spoiler alert guys is this
scissors spoilers
I know I'm just
spoiler alert chat
if she hasn't already
there
you can't afford to let them leave
remember she has thanks for the Bitties
guys
what about you
before or after I catch my breath
sorry sorry
come on toggle
toggle hi Caleb hi Caleb
ah thank you Jenny yo it's thanks to
scoring Enix guys and you guys too
obviously you guys have done so much for
me
why are you wearing a mask um because
there's a lot of people around there's
that you don't need to wear a mask but I
mean I just like protecting myself
you know
is America America why wear a mask
I just want to wear a mask there's a lot
of people here that aren't but I just
choose to wear one
am I supposed to go this way I don't
know where I'm going
to get somewhere she must be here
somewhere
yeah it's just I don't know
I feel like I'm gonna get sick anyway
like I'm gonna go back home and catch a
cold from here because it's different
weather
yeah she protecting herself versus yo
Caleb has an iron stomach hey look
there's your emotes give
[Music]
it's so she can't smell Caleb's broccoli
breath
wait where do I go so torgo's not coming
in here maybe I'm not supposed to be in
here
I think I'm done I have searched now we
can leave
Torgo
the door has been signal
oh some opponents will cast cure
to heal their allies defeat the
spellcasters
all right so you gotta go back and kill
the [__] healer
[Music]
second
what the hell man
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God Chad
yo I think we killed them
I think we killed them
ah Caleb want to play too
[Music]
yo I wonder if Caleb can sit in here and
play if he wants
did you talk to
you should ask them Caleb see
some people can finish early maybe you
can take the people spot who finish
early
thank you
yo man you gotta ask
I'm running out of tawa
how does a combat movement feel it's
very smooth it's very very smooth
no not everyone gets to stream guys so
there's only certain streamers that oh I
like this actually this picture here
um not every streamer got to get in on
it so
[Music]
I'm having a really good day guys it's
such a blessing to be here but I'm like
okay
so much talking
bad boy
get up boy get him boys
I'm such a like slasher hack and slash
guys I know I'm trying to use all the
abilities but I'm like just spamming
Square
wow I miss you guys too
hey Todd did you ask yeah
oh
I see
I see I see
wait I came from here didn't I
yeah I did come from there
I gotta go this way Chad
wait
yeah
I like it
[Music]
hi friends hi Haru yo Caleb can yo we
can climb ladders yeah yeah yeah isn't
it awesome
wait now what wait did I miss something
here
do I jump over
wait what
what the heck what's the point of that
being there
am I missing something no it didn't what
uh let's go up or maybe
there you go
oh yeah chance
that's it traditional Final Fantasy yeah
it's an open door and there's nothing
inside just like ff2 huh
oh
[__]
spellcasters oh here
second toggle
oh my God
yeah
wait there's another spell Caster you
just healed wait where is it
oh use the potion oh there he is I see
him by the door
there he is kill the Healer
[Music]
what
she better not have flown away
[Music]
Caleb is yuna's bodyguard now Caleb
party yeah it's Karen
I can't see
[Music]
how much time do I got left how tall I
am
wait no way
[Music]
I started at 6 45. but I'm wondering if
I can give the rest of like my half an
hour to use the stream that'd be I want
to share yeah Caleb I think it'd be nice
if I could if I'm allowed
if I'm allowed I can so you can stream
on your stream
you know I feel bad I like sharing I
know my community would appreciate that
too
you gotta share guys like
[Music]
[Applause]
I know
[Music]
[Applause]
our show will begin shortly
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
please welcome to the stage Final
Fantasy 16 composer Maza Yoshi soken and
game composer and content creator Alex
mukala
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody hello good people how
are we doing today
wow
welcome to the Final Fantasy 16 music
panel where we get to talk about the
music of this game with the legend lead
composer masary soken
Final Fantasy 16 years
how does it feel being in front of all
these beautiful fans here and also
online
so yeah um this is it's been a long time
since I've been able to make a
non-online game
um so a great experience for me I'm
really excited
yeah and by the way I don't know where
my manners are but I forgot to say my
name is Alex I'm a game composer and
content creator and it's
thank you guys
thank you it is a massive honor to be
here among friends fans and legends and
you guys as well like what's your son
and Helen guys thank you for what to do
thank you
[Applause]
obviously we're here to talk about the
music of Final Fantasy 16 and uh I'd
like to start by saying there was a
trailer that dropped at the game awards
the Revenge trailer of Final Fantasy 16.
I have to say the music team in that
trailer is stuck in my mind ever since I
heard it
so that's one of my favorite songs as
well
very good Great Taste yes
come on
so um for everyone that likes the song
you actually be able to possibly
experience in the demo that drops in
another couple hours oh my God
so yeah make sure you all play the demo
right yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go
well uh I was wondering how did you come
up with that song how did you write it
the Revenge team
um
so when making that track
I had to think about Joshua become
Joshua
um
okay um however
um what part of Joshua and what kind of
situation Joshua isn't I can't really
tell you about the net because if I told
you that my hero-san would kill me so we
need you to all play the game and then
you'll probably figure it out I love
Joshua by the way after playing the game
a little bit I fell in love with the
character it's so beautiful yeah amazing
characters
yeah yeah just as great as Joshua
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you
turn around
[Laughter]
come to me ifrito
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
foreign so again I want to talk a little
more with you but before that I want to
have someone join us here on the stage
uh
uh foreign
[Applause]
guys what an honor to be on stage with
you guys you guys are legends in this
English means a lot to be here with you
uh and hi everyone my name is Diego
Contreras I'm a film director and I am I
had the privilege of directing a
live-action short film and commercial
for Final Fantasy 16. I'm finished
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I am
[Applause]
guys guys
what just happened yeah you guys know
Final Fantasy could look that cool I've
been playing this game ever since I was
a kid and I
I can't find the words
also the the music
there was a guy beating the hammer at
the rhythm of the music that was being
played by the violin girl like that all
the Melodies we heard sound like The
Melodies that we heard in Traders but it
sounds like they were adapted especially
for this short film how was the process
of working on the music for this
um
all right I think Diego is probably
better equipped to answer that question
so let's hear from you so yeah from the
very beginning this film was written as
a musical which
is pretty unique for a live-action game
trailer it's different it's not all
action based uh with soaking sound
soundtrack acting as the
is this better
hey uh yeah so I was saying just the it
was written as a musical and so can
sound soundtrack was in a way acting as
the driving emotional force of the film
uh so every sound every instrument every
voice that you hear in the film is
building and building to tell an
emotional story of Clive's
transformation
I know
um
I mean this track is used used in Final
Fantasy 16 so many important parts of
the game and so we're giving to you we
knew that you were going to use it in a
very important way as well and I think
you were able to do that with um your
creation can we give a round of applause
to this man for what he did on the yeah
[Applause]
okay but there's one thing that I'd like
to ask you
foreign
like at the beginning I think we saw
like Torgo
so in the game Toro seems a lot bigger
and more full flank
yeah wasn't that tour was a little bit
too cute well that was actually the
plush animal that's been roaming around
[Laughter]
so I'll tell the story we actually first
of all the actor is very tall so that's
a real wolf but the actor makes him look
very small but we also
we had an out uh like an outfit that
would make him look bigger like a bigger
toggle but he looked like an Ikea rug
roaming around
so we've decided to take off all the the
extra coating that we had for Toro and
we just went with the real wolf
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie I cannot want Ikea
skin for toggling game now hello
[Laughter]
I have one question for you how did this
video come together in terms of like the
process you went through for creating it
is
yeah so it was a great collaboration
between Square Enix the team at Square
Enix the Ad Agency anomaly and the
production company that I work with love
song for over probably about a month
in um
writing the whole story uh discussing
every detail to make sure that it was
faithful to Final Fantasy
clinics
and we shot in Croatia across a major
stunning Landscapes and real medieval
towns and one of the one of the dreams
we had was to make this this film feel
real and grounded in reality not CGI
so we shot in real locations it's all in
camera except for Ifrit at the end but
it's all in camera there's no green
screen what do you mean if it is not
real
we try to cast the actual effort but his
rate was too high
[Laughter]
[Music]
I know it is
foreign
um thank you for having me
uh yeah I've been playing games like
this since I was a little kid and
honestly it's been a dream to be a part
of this and help bring this world to
Final Fantasy 16 to life on film so
thank you it's an honor guys thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
yes live action Final Fantasy that was
so freaking cool
so yeah the music in that um again we've
used that melody in the game but we did
a special Arrangement just uh for that
movie I get the feeling that
I mean I almost cried when I watched
this now but I have to be professional
and not cry in front of thousands of
people but I also get the feeling that
after beating the game and watching that
again it will hit me in a different ways
military
[Music]
so yeah I mean not not just that trailer
I mean you could once you finish the
game go back and watch all the trailers
and there's no way that you're not gonna
cry
[Laughter]
in here didn't come here to talk about
crying so
music I wanted to ask you a question
about that actually okay how did you
feel when they told you you were gonna
write the music for Final Fantasy 16.
maybe you cried up Joy or cried of pain
because you're like this is gonna be too
hard I don't know anymore
knock us into
no no
it's a hair
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Final Fantasy 14. do you give them all
today
[Applause]
so yeah um as you know I'm already
working hard on Final Fantasy 14. so
when they asked me to do Final Fantasy
16 well that's one hell and now two
Hells
you made it through yeah
[Applause]
so um there's one thing that I really
wanted to talk about about Final Fantasy
16's music
and so um we talked about the two Hells
and how much fun I had traversing
through them
foreign
so um I thought you know if this project
is going to be hell why not have some
fun and so I tried wanted to try to do
something that we had never done before
so Alex I want to ask you a question how
are you at um action games I'm pretty
good I'm pretty good animation
[Laughter]
why does he have to call me out like
cool guys
foreign
so um again because Final Fantasy 16 is
an action game
um you know the battles are going to be
carried out differently depending on how
good you are um at an action game
foreign
so when someone is really good at action
games plays those battles are going to
end pretty quickly on someone who's not
so good at action games place the battle
never ends
foreign
and so you probably know this but with
game music it's all about that situation
when you get a certain spot in in the
game and that Melody hits or that
Arrangement hits and it the music fits
with what's going on in the game yeah it
feels like when you're you're in a music
video almost
foreign
game this time and like we mentioned
before with different play Styles it's
difficult to make that happen
Ing
and that all comes down to timing
because the timing is going to be
different those battle links are going
to be different depending on who's
playing
onaji
but for Final Fantasy 16 we found a way
to make a similar game sound experience
for all different types of players we
developed this certain kind of magic to
make it happen magic oh my God
oh my God
so this is very difficult to explain I'm
just by talking so we've brought a video
to kind of show you how it's done
so let's watch the first video
[Music]
thank you
nice trick
[Music]
s
so yeah that's the same track you
noticed from the Diego's trailer as well
I have a question about the piece of
music I'll ask you later yeah okay
[Laughter]
all right and so now we have a second
version of that video where the vowel is
a little bit different length
so you probably just don't know what
happened did you
say but that's okay
um again so we have cast a magic spell
uh on the actual battle so that when
you're playing you're not gonna notice
um that the music is changing it's all
just gonna feel smooth
and so you can kind of think of it like
this so Alex you have your PlayStation
5. I'm inside that PlayStation 5. and
while you're playing I'm there editing
the music making sure things are coming
at the right time so what you're telling
me is that every single player is gonna
have their own personal magical soccer
in their PlayStation yes
[Laughter]
so that is to make sure that if I
understand this correctly you don't want
a moment in the boss fight where the
boss is doing something epic like and
the music gets sad like you want the
music to match the epicness if it's
necessary
so
um yeah that's exactly right
um that's not to say that there are some
battles that we do something different
um for example there are some battles
where you know when the battle ends and
Clyde will do a really cool pose
so yeah so for Alex you'd be like this
right
yeah that's what I do yeah
and so like when you know Clive does
that cool move or you do that cool move
we want the music to match that move and
come at a swell and bring it all at that
moment right wow so what you're saying
is players of any kind you know the
amazing players like you and the best
players like me apparently are gonna get
the same experience
yeah I mean we talked about I mean you
know you said it was a great gamer I
mean I'm really good at OverWatch but
I'm not that really good at 16 so I see
I see I see
I believe
do we have some time for fan questions
all right okay
this one you may not see coming I said
before I wanted to ask you a question
about that theme in the boss
um then Melody many people recognize
that it's quite similar to the Erica
Melody from Final Fantasy 14. is there a
reason for that
foreign
[Music]
okay
um so with a lot of the songs that I
make um you know I do it two ways
um
one way is when a song sounds similar to
another one it's because I'm doing it on
purpose
the other time is it's because
that's fair uh I also want to talk a
little bit about you guys partners in
crime
one amazing thing that I noticed in
Final Fantasy 16 there's this new track
that dropped called find the flame
and it sounds like the choir is singing
quite the flame and it's so cool because
I'm like oh okay I'll find it
I feel so motivated right I felt that
way also in Final Fantasy 14 when the
shutterbringer Squire is singing riding
home yeah yeah and it's so cool to play
a Japanese game and you're a choir
English lyrics singing to me
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
um so um I mean I've been you know
working in sound for a long time
um and after coming to square I mean I
think it was maybe about
um 15 years ago that I had uh first
opportunity to work
um with coaching with me foreign
and then the first thing I thought is
wow this guy can be really useful
[Laughter]
tonight
and so I was working on this game and um
I needed someone to rap for me
[Laughter]
and then you know it happened that I was
near the studio that day
and it's like oh hey you rap
video
and yeah and then I had to rap and so I
mean it was a game with Mario and it's
just like
I remember that game I played it as a
kid and I loved it
is
so cool
[Applause]
and then um he's been using me in game
since then um and then it happened that
we both ended up working on Final
Fantasy 14 and because Final Fantasy 14
is a game we're selling around words
like Hey we're selling it around the
world let's use English oh yeah that's
Koji hey help me out man
and so I started out just writing the
lyrics for the songs
that's right um but then you know I
write the lyrics but he's like but I
mean I don't know how how do you how do
you sing them Koji can you just give me
a sample of how to sing the lyrics
yeah
but over there
laughs
I love it I don't think I need to
translate that part
and so um I do the sample and he's like
yeah we don't need to take anymore
that's good enough
and then we have a song
I heard a rumor that you guys have a
song in 16 as well where you're singing
together is that true
[Applause]
maybe maybe
well I'm excited to hear it if it exists
yeah I mean again if it's us singing it
it's not going to be something like oh
and beautiful you know what it's going
to be
hahaha
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well sounds like we're almost out of
time yeah
foreign
[Music]
I mean I'm here on stage with you we're
both musicians
[Music]
let's do something we gotta collab I
mean let's try it I'd love to so you
guys want to hear it yeah
[Applause]
all right and because you know we're
here for Final Fantasy 16 we got to do a
final fantasy 16 song all right let's
see let's let's give our best company
so you mentioned uh the trailer before
the Revenge trailer and you really like
the track and that's always stuck in
your head let's do that ah okay let's do
it okay
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready
when you are okay
okay
one
two
one two three four
[Music]
thanks
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys thank you very much
all right so that's the end of our panel
here um but we have one last tiny panel
where we're bringing everyone back up on
the stage to say our goodbyes so please
stick around
for Alex
thank you guys
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
our show will begin shortly
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the stage the Final
Fantasy 16 development team
[Music]
foreign
it's been a very long show thank you
everyone here and watching on the stream
for sticking with us to the end
um
um and while it's been almost five hours
um it feels like it went by really
quickly
um but we'd like to bring the show here
uh to an end but before we do we'd like
to get the comments from each uh of the
development team
so let's begin with takaisan hi um
and
um
all right so uh we have 10 days until
our launch on June 22nd
um I'm super excited and I know you are
too so to bite the time uh I might have
suggest playing the demo that drops
later today I hope you really really
like it thank you everyone for today
it's been great
foreign
we worked really hard uh on to make
Final Fantasy 16's narrative a truly
engaging experience and like I said at
the panel um we're excited to get the
game in your hands um and have you
experienced the game all the way to the
end and when you do please give us your
feedback we'd love to hear it thank you
very much
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right again thank you everyone so
much um we've developed Final Fantasy 16
to be enjoyable and accessible um to
both hardcore action Gamers and
newcomers alike
um but my real hope is that through
Final Fantasy 16 we can get those
players who are maybe not so good at
action games or maybe have never played
action games to come into the genre and
learn to truly love it like I do
okay
and so um you know I've been working
very very hard on both 14 and Final
Fantasy 16 but it's finally time for me
to come here on stage and be with all
you so excited
characters yo
stand there is
okay um and because I was able to
Traverse these two Hells it got me ready
and made me able to create such a great
music for Final Fantasy 16 we have these
wonderful themes for the characters we
have these wonderful Melodies and so
when you play
take that volume turn it up just a
little bit more than usual
um for me
um I have spent the last several years
working on this very very wonderful game
not being able to talk about it a lot
but being able to be here tell you all
about the game and the experience and
also getting the opportunity to work
with these wonderful devs I mean let's
just give these guys a hand these guys
I am really excited to have Final
Fantasy 16 now I know you guys are as
well and I hope you really really enjoy
the game thank you very much
[Applause]
and I just want to say what an absolute
pleasure and honor it's been to be able
to deliver the voice of this wonderful
deaf team to you guys and the same as
all of you I absolutely can't wait to
jump into the world of Valencia thank
you all so much for having me here
[Applause]
with a few final words from myself
and so um like I said before um our demo
for Final Fantasy 16 is dropping in only
a few hours
um this is going to be the first time we
get the game in the hands of everyone
out there we've been working on this
game uh for so long remember back when
we started just with a few members
growing the team
um working so hard to get this game out
to you we're really excited
tonight
foreign
and again while we have some great Dev
team members here today there are a lot
of Dev team members that weren't able to
make the trip to Los Angeles but they
all worked very very hard to create
something that is very truly truly
special and we truly believe that we've
created something special here and we
can't wait to get in your hands and have
you play through it get to the end and
give us all your feedback
I'm off
foreign
again I want to thank everyone who came
here today um you braved the cold
um to help be here with us
yeah
you want to thank everyone over there
all of our uh influencers and streamers
who are in streaming the game to the
world and showing everybody how exciting
Final Fantasy 16 can be
uh
we want to thank everyone who is
watching us today on the stream all
around the world
all right so remember Final Fantasy 16
on sale worldwide June 22nd
and so for us um once this is over we're
going to be heading back to Japan
um but before launch we hope to have uh
maybe a live letter like a live
performance maybe in Japan
um so if you have the time maybe check
it out
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I thought I was ready for this I know
but we will face it together
let's shut him up I am a shield of
Rosaria and I will do my duty
come on
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us today
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]